SPARE, SHOT. MINUTES IN.
22 DID BY DOBSON.
GOES TO THE SIDE
SVECHNIKOV.
GOOD WORK BY THE RKING TOWARDS
CORNER.
SOROKIN . A TURNOVER.
FAST. N AT
AND HE DOES.
THAT IS WHAT
>> Mike: FACE-OFF TO THE RI29.
UP AND OUT.
LETOP.
HISTORY.
SHOT IS DEFLECTED BY BALL.
ACROSS.
AND IS 12 SHOT WITH KICKED AWAY
JARVIS.
SLAVIN, WITH HIS GREAT PASS.
ONE HERE IN CAROLINA.
WE ARE UNDERWAY IN THE SECOND
PERIRIUP TO 22.
HIS LONGTIME APPEARED
SECOND ONE.
HE IS NOT ONLY  TO
CLIPPER CANNOT FIND IT OUT TO
PARISE.
U DO NOT GET
THROUGH IT.
IN YOUR ARMS TO THE E
NO CHANCE FOR
HEAVY HIT
BYTEDANCE
THE PUCK GOES INTO THE CORNER.
ANDERSEN HAS TO BE READY.
YOU MAKE  THE SAVE. ING TO HAVE
LIKE AWAY.
ANDERSEN.
T THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT ANES.
VINCENT TROCHECK  THE BOARD.
VINCENT EASILY COULD HAVE
BECOME A SPECTATOR AFTER HE GOT
IT TO TONY. THE NET.
KYLE PALMIERI BOWLED HIS PREVEN
FREDDY FROM DOING HIS